the idea is really simple just to rewind
a little bit
it's whenever you're talking about two
quantities and you know customarily we
say x and y two quantities are related
to each other in some way and they
change together so that's what that's my
translation for direct variation
variation means change and the idea of
direct means I think this might ring a
bell when one gets bigger the other gets
bigger they're going in the same
direction so that's why I say they do it
together as opposed to like in
opposition to each other okay like so
now our symbol for that is this guy do
you remember that one there so you can
also say that this is proportionality so
when two things change together they
stay in proportion to each other so it's
like you double one well the other one
also gets twice the size what was
something like that okay so this idea of
proportionality is another way of saying
I guess that there's direct variation
these things are getting bigger or
smaller together okay now what kinds of
things could be x and y
give me some examples that you can think
of two things that say as you increase
one the other one also increases calorie
intake and weight gain
they don't do me okay sure that's all
right I am that's that's a fine one as I
sit my high sugar white chocolate hot
Ravi that's fine okay sure
so all right as on as calorie intake
goes up weight gain presumably also goes
up now this is an interesting one
because would probably say that calorie
intake it's not like you take one extra
calorie and you put on one extra gram
that's that's not like you know it does
that'll be really depressing it's like
wow I'm gonna put
put on 300 grams you know so there's not
a nice neat relationship there maybe the
relationship looks something like this
let's draw like a little rough graph
yeah so if I go calories and weight I
actually do well here brunette you do PE
I don't know if your company something
like this but probably not because it's
nutrition its nutrition in PE right
don't worry it's one there are heaps and
heaps of rows that's right that's right
of course of course
yeah good job Akhil okay well I'm gonna
do it like I'm gonna do it like this I'm
just going to draw a ridiculously
simplified graph the reason why I'm
going to reap the the purpose in me
doing it like this my reason for it is I
would suggest that I suppose early on as
you take calories actually there's
hardly any weight gain right because
your body's metabolizing that and using
it for stuff okay so early on is you
increase calories very little weight
gain happens but then as you add more
and more on at a certain point your your
body's like I can't do anything with
these calories
guess I'll store them and hence the
weight gain right so that's why the
weight starts to take off okay now the
idea of direct variation is we're trying
to search for straight lines we're
trying to search for things that don't
look just like this we want things that
look more like this okay
so let's actually put some numbers on
this I'm going to manufacture some
numbers and I'm going to make them
really nice and intentionally
artificially simple just so that we can
see how you can go from something like
this and you can actually create a graph
like this I'm gonna put some numbers on
here let's go one two three four I can
just fit that on one two three four
let's suppose for 1000 calories or a
thousand I don't know whatever unit
you'd like I'm just going to call this
energy because I don't actually know how
many calories how many
Jules or anything like that yeah I'm
just gonna call it energy because that's
what it is energy versus weight for one
two three four units of energy mystery
units let's suppose if you consume one
unit of energy you're gonna put on one
kilogram of weight
okay I'm gonna say two it goes up to
four three it goes up to nine and four
goes up to six deep okay let's um let's
go simpler again rather than calling
these weight and energy how about we do
what mathematicians love to do and just
call these W and E huh that's my
initials anyway whatever and what we've
got here is a relationship between E and
W there's a variation there there's some
proportionality they both go up together
okay now I can create a table out of
this okay
I can create a table that map's W
against eight I can compare these two we
can create this quite easily so if I
have my e values and my double unit
values my energy and weight I just went
simple numbers one two three and four
and then I went 1 4 9 and 16 okay now if
I want to turn this which is a curvy
line into a straight line you guys can
see why I've chosen 1 4 9 and 16 right
one of those they're they're just square
numbers okay so what I'm gonna do down
here is I'm going to create a new table
it's going to still have e on the top so
that's just one two three and four but
what I'm going to put down the bottom is
not W I'm gonna put the square root of W
okay hmm
now I have all my W numbers up here yeah
so all I have to do to get these numbers
is just take all the square roots of the
numbers I have up there and I chose them
because they were so easy and what are
the square roots of one four nine
sixteen one two three and four
aha now when you look at this when you
look at this each of these is a set of
coordinates right one one is the set of
coordinates I get from this first column
2 2 & 3 3 & 4 4 so if I were to put
these guys onto my graph they would all
fit on a nice neat straight line like so
fantastic okay so what have we done
we've got new graph it still connects
energy and weight but not the way this
did not just by measuring some numbers
we actually had to twist and turn them a
little bit so I'm actually comparing
energy not with W but with the square
root of W okay now why do we like
straight lines why are we obsessed with
turning curve things into straight lines
is because straight lines are easy to
read when we're trying to use a graph to
make decisions or or try and understand
a population we generally do two things
we either their rulers we either
extrapolate we look beyond what the data
is I wonder what would happen if I
consumed a hundred units of energy I
don't have data for that but maybe I can
use this pattern to extrapolate further
okay or does anyone remember what is it
what's the opposite that when you look
inside your data
what's that corn starts with an eye very
close when you go outside it's called
extrapolate English right
when you go inside its interpolation so
you interpolate okay so what would
happen if I consumed 1.5 units of energy
or 3.5 or something like that I don't
actually have a measurement for it I
don't have like I did an experiment and
I collected some data I'm just guessing
but I'm guessing off of this model okay